uh we're going to talk about mass
m
is as with most symbols in physics gets
used for multiple things but the most
common use for m is to refer to the mass
of something um
what we don't know about mass is
probably
more interesting
m is for mass so i've got
a nice
sphere which is a chinese metal ball for
relaxing me and this weighs as i put it
in the scales 140 grams as you can see
it's a complicated concept to explain
because mass has two
two effects there are two things that
that that mass matters for and this is
what people normally mean by mass solid
object which is really heavy
and compact but the dictionary says that
there are two different definitions
according to chambers one is gravity um
the more massive an object is the
stronger its pull of gravity is this is
the mass which acts downwards pulling
this towards the earth and if it's a
heavier object that is it has more mass
or if i put on weight as i stand on the
scales i weigh more this is a smaller
mass which came from the red nose day a
few years ago and you put that on there
and it hardly moves and i weigh it at
about five grams so you can actually
measure the difference between these two
quantities
and the other is how much something
doesn't like being pushed around so if
you've got something that has a very
high mass it has it really doesn't like
being you know you have to push it very
hard to get it to move at all now
there's another aspect of the mass
according to my version of chambers
dictionary and that is its reluctance to
move if something has a very low mass
then then it's very easy to make it move
so if i put these objects here
and try to measure how reluctant this
object is to move i can flick that
and i'll do this with full vigor
and it really moves did you see that
oh i'll pick it up again
and in some ways it's sort of one of the
one of the great unknowns of physics one
of the great unexplained things of
physics is to why
mass matters for both of these things
and it's basically you can use the same
number to explain both how strong
something's gravitational pull is and
also how much it doesn't like being
pushed around and now i'll do it with
this one with the same figure although
i'm very reluctant to because i know
and you can see that it moves but it's
more reluctant to move and doesn't go
with the same speed in fact it hurt my
hand that is called the inertia of the
object and it's the inertial mass of the
object it's the reluctance to move in in
the dictionary it said it's the
resistance but i prefer to think of the
object as wanting to stay still to be
inert and it wants to stay where it is
so those are the aspects of mass that we
know about right from our childhood but
the really fundamental question that
hasn't been answered is what causes mass
that's again uh
there you're you're
venturing into very deep water i have to
say if you really want to answer that
question you have to ask a particle
physicist because they're the people who
really understand these fundamental
properties of matter as far as an
astronomer is concerned it's just the
property that
objects have
and we're quite happy to accept it as
such
and this is one of the questions that
we're hoping that the large hadron
collider might answer
if it uncovers the higgs boson this is a
big particle that we think might be
involved with
making objects actually have mass but
nobody has actually seen it yet
what is the origin of the mass of the
electron or the mass of the proton or
the mass of a quark or any fundamental
particle because there is no
um there is a theory but the theory
hasn't been properly tested so it's
still hypothesis there's a theory due to
peter higgs of edinburgh that says
there's a huge field throughout the
universe
permeating everywhere with a particle
associated called the higgs boson and it
is the presence of this field coupling
to each particle which gives them mass
but nobody yet knows whether this theory
is right whether it's one higgs boson ii
or whatever and that's the current state
of play
people have asked this question william
waldergrave set a bet about 10 years ago
it must be more because he was in the
conservative government to ex that he
would give a prize to the best
explanation what a higgs boson was
and
the winning answer or something like the
winning answer was that
imagine you go into a
cocktail party and you're very
attractive so you found a 10 pound note
and you're saying i've just found 10
pounds who dropped it everybody would
come rushing towards you
and then if you tried to move through
the party you will be surrounded by
people and find it very difficult to
move whereas if you
came in and said i've just lost 10
pounds
has anybody found it you'll find
everybody move away from you and that
would be an anti-big higgs boson so i
think it the the simple-minded picture
which has no mathematics is this idea of
accreting mass to you because you are
attractive in some way
just as the 10-pound note would be
attractive
and so you find it difficult to move and
it's your reluctance to move against all
these people clustering around you which
is a simple mental picture i have
well in astronomy oftentimes we don't
use the most sensible units for
measuring mass so in in truth sometimes
we talk about measuring things like the
mass of the sun in grams or kilograms
um which gets into very very large
numbers as with everything in astronomy
the numbers get so big that they become
completely meaningless so it's you know
one with an awful lot of zeros after it
well the large hadron collider
is meant to be working at energy such
that they would be able to detect the
higgs boson if it's there
the energy range covers it but then
unfortunately as soon as they got it up
and running uh the helium leaked out and
the whole thing
well there's huge amount of damage and
it's gone back by about six months so in
the next few years maybe we'll detect
the higgs boson and then
i'll find out more about it whether it's
right or not in my line of work i'm
talking about the mass of galaxies or
even clusters of galaxies and these are
some of the largest objects that we know
about in the whole universe so what we
tend to do is actually measure things
not in kilograms but actually in units
that are kind of more associated with
the things we're interested in so for
example the main mass unit that
astronomers use is the solar mass the
mass of the sun and that's kind of a
useful number because for example if you
figure out that some galaxy weighs 10
billion times the mass of the sun that
immediately gives you a feeling that
it's probably an object that's probably
got about 10 billion stars like the sun
in it
even then the sun is so small compared
to these large numbers that we have to
talk in terms of billions or thousands
of billions or millions of billions of
times the mass of the sun
i i grew up in the 50s and 60s
and then we all had imperial units and
so i had to learn grains and ounces
and pounds and stone
one after stone 100 weights and
tons do you remember all those they were
very difficult there are 16 grains in an
ounce and 16 ounces in a in a pound and
14 pounds
all these things and so you learned your
multiplication tables but now we use
kilograms meters second for everything
and rationalize everything
and it's certainly nicer but there's
more flavor to the old units because
when you talk about grains you're really
talking about going back to babylonian
times and measuring things in terms of
grains of wheat or whatever
or if you go back to roman times you
talk about hands and feet and yards
and in spanish
the inch is called the pulgada which is
just this part of your thumb
because objects in astronomy can get to
be pretty big you end up with rather a
lot of solar masses but for some reason
we don't actually use anything much
heavier than the mass of the sun
occasionally people kind of use a
typical mass of a galaxy but but more
often than not we just measure
everything in solar units the mass of
the sun so it's not always the most
efficient way
but at least it brings it back to
something that we can actually
comprehend in our heads
can you can you comprehend the mass of
the sun in your head uh
yeah probably not
there is a feeling that this was a
french system set up by napoleon
and it was one of the best things he
ever did in many ways inventing the
meter
inventing the kilogram
and somehow the english still love to
have
uh the old-fashioned pound but if you go
and live in france they'll they'll talk
about i would like to have a demi-levera
which is half a pound of something in
french so these old units
that you grow up with and a part of the
language and culture they stay even if
you have been exposed to metric systems